maybe I should do one little update on
Brent since that sagas going on we were
talking yesterday about going out to LA
and then the shocking revelation came
out that when Brent is out in California
his wife has said you can go [ __ ]
whoever you want just when you come home
tell me about it and then Brent said
that his wife now will be on a [ __ ]
spree super still he's gone while he's
gone and she can [ __ ] people I heard
something even more intense what that
Brent is now in the middle of
interviewing men to [ __ ] his wife while
he's gone is that true uh yes Wow what
do you be a who's showing up for these
interviews and what kinds of questions
are you ask
well it's interview as a by the way
there's a big line up outside the house
right now
it's people it's guys that are in the
swingers commune okay so we're gonna
meet a guy and I'm gonna you know have a
couple we're gonna have a couple of
drinks with him I just want to make sure
it's cool what type of questions where
you ask at the interview having drinks
and getting to know you type the I see
it's not a they've got an interview it's
like it's a conversation Wow I don't get
to know the guy yeah Benji you will not
allow it's it's not up to me it's up to
Kaitlyn and Kaitlyn's up if Kaitlyn says
to you Benji is gonna come over to the
house and [ __ ] me it's it's up to her
but I guarantee you she like that be
saying to me like oh you're gonna [ __ ]
some woman with that woman with big
sloppy tits like I'm not you know she's
in it for her pleasure not right she
could give her pleasure I just don't
think that she's attracted to Benji no
one else yeah but let's say she was okay
wouldn't be awkward it would be no you
don't even want her showing her vagina
to him yeah I don't but I just don't I
don't want her you know kind of crossing
the work original line so I don't want
here income [ __ ]
I'd rather not I'd rather not understood
I'd probably like to [ __ ] her though
right I mean I like that there's a rule
against me and I don't like those
comments you made about me man
what comment fat guy [ __ ] her guys
really a hard-boiled egg with a beard